odd rumors are bound to follow you
around and you're as big of a star as
Tom Cruise but the actor and his recent
collaborators are saying in knowing
certain terms that the strangest rumor
about him is completely false speaking
with the times in July 2023 mission
impossible that Reckoning part 1
director Christopher macquarrie
explained that the first time he and
Cruz met the director asked the star
about the strangest rumor he had ever
heard about himself Crews declared that
it was the persistent story that he buys
people who work on his sets from looking
him in the eye the long-held rumor about
his behavior reportedly mystified the
Superstar actor and he has categorically
denied that it's the case this tall tale
about Cruz apparently goes back to
shooting 1999's Magnolia in that film
Cruz plays Frank an intense motivational
speaker who has been bitterly estranged
from his father who abandoned him to
care for his dying mother but is now
dying himself that's the kind of role
that make anyone look inward it was also
in a typical role for Cruz and would
explain why he may have behaved
differently on that set than another say
no
you will not control me no
you will not take my soul in any event
Cruz's recent co-stars are willing to go
on the record to defend his onset
Behavior Simon Pega appears in a number
of Mission Impossible films as Benji
done spoke up for Cruz in the same the
times Round Table explaining that he
spent happy social time after set with
Crews on numerous occasions including
zip lining and other activities with a
dead reckoning crew Pegg said I've been
able to hack my way through all the
bizarre mythology that surrounds him on
one side he's Cruz this enigmatic film
star everyone wants to know about and on
the other he's just a guy I like being
normal with him Pegg also defended
Cruz's Outburst on the mission
impossible dead reckoning par 1 set
where he was caught in an audio
recording losing it on a crew member who
was alleged for broken covid-19
protocols Peg explained everything that
Tom cares about in terms of his job was
at stake due to the pandemic for him
there was a danger this virus could wipe
Cinema off the face of this Earth that
said while a number of the Stars
collaborators say the eye contact rumor
is false and defend his other Behavior
yeah at least one co-star has declared
that cruise is very protective of one of
his trademarks running on film I've just
been an athlete my whole life gymnastics
and I'd love to Sprint since I came out
running it takes some serious work to
convince him to let anyone run with him
according to Annabelle Wallace who
worked with Cruz on 2017's the mummy she
told The Hollywood Reporter in 2020 that
she had to coaster Megastar into
sprinting by her side Wallace said I got
to run on screen with him but he told me
no at first he said nobody runs on
screen with me and I said but I'm a
really good runner so I would tie my
treadmill so that I had walk in and see
me run and then he added all these
running scenes that said Cruz has
clearly been willing to Sprint beside
some other co-stars for one he can be
seen running side by side with Kobe
smolders in 2016's Jack Reacher never go
back but she had to train for it too
smolders even told the Press she had to
learn how to match Cruiser's pace and
speed copying his signature style so is
some Crews protective of the things that
make him Tom Cruise yes but it also
seems like he's more approachable than
the rumors make him out to be